we hear this uh fight that's going to go
down someone
uh named logan paul and may what whether
is
is this you're going to be a muslim
brother my brother another youtuber
named ksi that actually turned pro he
logan paul has one fight against him how
would you break that fight down
mayweather and logan if it happens how
would you break it down yeah we see you
here
in this uh little video clip you're
actually at a jummah making salah you're
praying like jesus this is how jesus
prayed do you think someone like him he
would just have to have four wives
it's four there's a maximum four i i'll
take four whites
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean shawn may to your
host subscribe if you haven't already
and hit that notification bell support
us on our patreon page my next guest
was part of that video that went viral
he stopped people wanted to know why and
we're gonna find out why did he stop
everything he was doing he's hanging out
with mike tyson
and then he stopped to pray with who
mike tyson why did he do that in the
middle of the day so we're gonna be
talking about that and also
he's part of the mayweather camp he is a
light heavyweight champion
super middleweight champion 2008
olympian
and he's part of the mayweather camp so
we're going to talk about
this possible matchup between floyd
money
mayweather and logan paul is that really
going to happen
we're going to get a breakdown of that
and how that would go here with baldur
jack on the d show
good to finally connect with you yeah
how have you been great great i'm just
uh you know take care of my family here
you know relaxing in las vegas starting
my training camp
but you live in uae is that right
sorry you live you you're not full-time
there this just for your camp now
no no i i'm full-time here so so i moved
to dubai for
for a couple of months and then we
change our mind uh
move back to the stage okay so for our
audience that don't know
you're a light heavyweight champion
super middleweight champion
also 2008 olympian what else did i leave
out
um i don't know
that that's pretty much it for right now
i've been i'm supposed to be a fighter
a five-time world champion but like i've
been robbed on a couple of decisions but
alhamdulillah there was a a video that
went viral can you walk us through it
i did a reaction to it i don't know if
you had a chance to check it out
and it was you next to
mike tyson and then we had our brother
uh
amir abdullah and he was leading the
prayer
you know that video who was that who was
that man next to mike
yeah that's a handsome brother right
here that was
so that was you next to mike tyson yes
yes so i've been knowing mike since i
moved to vegas
back in 2011 and uh him and his team
they've always been uh you know
supportive of my career
and everything so tyson actually walked
me out to the ring
my first tv fight in 2012
and um so we got the call a couple of
months ago
or this summer if i wanted to be a part
of the co-main event for mike tyson vs
roy jones
i said wow they coming back i said yeah
of course
and uh yeah so they invited us to uh to
his ranch
uh to his training camp and um
so his um what you call the thriller is
the name of the
the channel the app that that's going to
show the fight
and they keep following him everywhere
he go and
film everything and uh me and ahmed it
was uh we gotta pray
uh
[Music]
and they was filming everything and then
then ahmed asked
tyson is it okay if they film he said i
want to pray with you guys
of course of course they can film if if
you guys are okay with it so tyson asked
us
if we were okay with it so of course
this is your house
mashallah so mike tyson said i want to
pray with you guys
yeah marshall and it was do her time
beautiful see isn't that amazing i mean
so why for the for the people out there
they're like what are you guys doing
okay so they're seeing this video right
now
it's the middle of the day and you guys
are stopping to pray for some people
this is like
why are you doing that i mean what's the
significance behind this and this is a
part of your life obviously
yeah obviously i mean we're muslims and
it don't matter where we are
i mean we gotta we gotta pray
and when people say oh who you guys
praying to
what do you tell them
to the creator of the heavens and earth
huh it's amazing it's the same god that
jesus worshiped that moses this is the
one creator of the heavens and the earth
yeah there's only one god and you're
thanking the one who gave you the
ability
to do all the beautiful things that are
human beings able to do i mean many
people don't you know realize how
beautiful this prayer is and this is
what was fascinating to see you guys
come together
and to make this a lot and to stop i
mean people like get nervous
they get like you know they're around
you know maybe some celebrities or
whatnot
or you know functions and they just
forget about the prayer but you guys
didn't do that
no absolutely not even mike tyson he
even told me that he never prayed in his
ranch before
you know he just need to be surrounded
by great people i mean he
already got some great people around him
but he was so happy that we
you know pray for them and he's such a
humble guy
it's crazy isn't that amazing let's talk
about let's stop right there
look how much uh friends and good
company can have an influence on you and
you
you awaken the fitra what you did
to him and now you you reminded him he
would just saw what you're saying so
excited and happy to make sajdah again
look at this
right right you know i'm actually going
back there tomorrow
tomorrow evening so yeah i'm gonna see
him again
hopefully give him salams give him
salams from us over here from the dean's
show
that'd be nice if you could make that
happen that'd be awesome
yeah i'll do my best how about how about
we i was with your boy the other day too
uh amir uh you guys know each other huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah we actually never
met but yeah but we've been uh linking
up on social media um
he's gonna come and visit me in training
camp i think uh
maybe next week or or so so when you
come to the west coast
i want to thank you and also your your
manager
because i mean this is something where a
lot of times
we have people who are in the spotlight
famous people celebrities
and they might be muslim but then they
shy away
and then sometimes the managers or
whoever they don't want to kind of
associate themselves you know with
anything has to do with their deen
they're shy kind of undercover
you know what i'm saying but uh amir
abdullah you guys you're proud to
represent the dean you're proud to be
muslim proud to like we saw praying
in public yeah definitely definitely
there's definitely not nothing to be
shy about to be embarrassed this is the
most beautiful blessing you can have
alhamdulillah this is so beautiful to
see it's so beautiful to see so what at
what
what had you really start you know
turning your life to the dean
you know really living the purpose of
life at what point of your life did you
start going towards that way
so um my mom is uh from sweden my dad is
from gambia
gambia is 95 muslims so i grew up in
sweden
um i mean i've always been muslim but
i've never really been practicing
until lately so i mean lately probably
i would say maybe in 2014 i start first
of all i got married
and then i started you know going to the
friday uh
to do my preparation in vegas did a
quite little
and uh you know start learning a little
bit then you know
i met uh i became a world champion and
all the
i think everything started happening
after i i did that i took
you know one step a lot took a thousand
steps to me
so i mean it just little by little i'm
trying to learn more i'm trying to
you know be a better person every day
and get closer to my religion
the difference between when you are not
practicing and practicing
describe that to us i mean
everything in life and like i i've been
more mature
i have i had two beautiful kids now
beautiful wife beautiful family
everything so i mean
it just made me a better person in
in all aspects of life so and i mean
just a blessing again i'm
being more humble my career
everything is going like from this to
this
you know do you do you see that do you
see that being a dangerous thing when
people start getting fame
money popularity you know ego starts
taking over
arrogance you know you get the money you
get all of the stuff
you know the people sweating you and you
know and now the ego
just uh you lose that humbleness or it's
just you it's hard to attain
i know people that know me i'm the same
person that i was before
or i'm trying to be a better person but
you know i always
uh you know i can't forget where i came
from so when i first started here
in las vegas i had like a bad management
situation i was living in a bad
neighborhood
yeah i didn't have no money or nothing
but i worked hard
and you know i don't never forget those
times so even
if i you know live a good life right now
as far as the
you know economic uh
point i i live good but uh you know i
never never forget where i came from
alhamdulillah so islam islam helps you
to kee keep it well balanced
helps you to stay humble everything
to not uh means
overlook my opponents in the ring
program anything could happen in boxing
anything can happen in life so
so it definitely helped me uh to stay
humble stay
motivated help me with everything i'm
just trying to
learn more
tell us about this picture you recently
posted a picture and what what what
significance does this have you know
what message
when you see in the picture you have
what is this
the person who's leading a prayer kind
of like you were praying with mike tyson
and brother abdullah
but now in this picture you have the
imam
is what the is it the cleaner there at
the hospital two doctors
and an officer oh yeah i reposted that
from
my brother
so that's the beauty of islam like
i think it was a cleaner or or something
like that and
he's holding the prayer in front of a
two doctors and a police officer that
that's the beauty of islam
yeah isn't it amazing it don't matter
how rich you are how poor you are
we all you know the same
who have been some of the greatest
influencers in your life
people who you looked up to i mean if i
if i mention a name like uh muhammad ali
what kind of impact has he had it had in
your life
oh he he is the greatest like they say
so yeah
definitely been a role model i mean
all the muslims uh rape muslims been
a great role model for me and like i'm
still learning i'm
still trying to
take things in and you know be a better
human being that that's what fascinates
me about muhammad ali that
he didn't shy away from letting people
know from giving dawah from being a
a great ambassador to islam and always
trying to share the message and always
trying to
you know not just live it uh live what
people knew him from inside the ring but
also outside the ring he didn't shy away
from it
right right even in those times in the
50s
when it was really bad yeah so
tell me now you have uh so you're part
of is
it uh correct uh how does mayweather
connect in your life
are you connected with his camp or
yeah so uh in 2000 it was 2013 i signed
with uh may with a promotion so
yeah he's my he's my promoter so um
um yeah we have been through a lot
together and
yeah how how we hear this uh fight
that's going to go down
someone uh named logan paul and may what
whether is is this is it is there any uh
we hear that the
it's been signed you know it's happening
uh
do you is this true or just it's just
gossip
i mean um to be honest i don't really
know but uh
you've heard what i'm talking about you
know what i'm talking about you you've
heard the same
rumors i heard rumors about it yeah
of course i i haven't talked to floyd
about it but you know he he's uh
he's had his great career even muhammad
ali did
exhibitions when he retired so this is
not if he fights logan paul
it's not a real fight it's an exhibition
so it's all about basically it's all
about
um getting them getting money
i mean he you can say whatever you want
about for he's always been
he's always been training like
he's broke so i mean he beat everybody
he did it his
his thing in his own career so now yeah
he he's trying to have some fun and do
exhibitions and stuff so
yeah but logan paul is not he's a
youtuber he's not a boxer
have you ever met logan paul yeah
actually there's another youtuber
named ksi that actually turned pro he
logan paul has one fight against him so
and that and that's a guy that i know a
little bit
so uh i was part of i walked into the
ring i was
sparring with him and you know preparing
him for the fight a little bit
so when ksi when ksi fought uh logan
paul
you were you walked out the ring with
him or to the ring with uh
ksi he's from uk right
at first i wasn't embarrassed because i
wasn't really want to be a part of the
youtube boxing thing but
you know it's always good uh you know to
show my face
and uh you know it was a fun fun event
so yeah i was there and i was supporting
my guy ksi and
yeah he won and it was actually the
crazy thing is they make more money than
most
boxers and it was sold out uh i think it
was
um what's the name center yeah
how would you break how we just have
some fun with this how would you break
that fight down mayweather
and logan if it happens how would you
break it down
because hey hey because hey uh uh
do you do you like to go by buddha jack
or by gabriel gabriel is also your your
your name right or how is it properly
yeah
so uh how how how would you uh because
he's heavier right he's also
logan logan is heavier by like what 50
pounds or something how much is he
heavier by
yeah i believe i believe he fought ksi
at cruiserweight which is like 200
pounds
and mayweather is like a 147 he walked
around
and uh yeah 150 at the most so
yeah it will probably be like 50 pounds
but yeah skills paid
floyd is the one of the best boxers of
our era
of our generation against the youtuber i
mean it don't really matter
what way it is
he wouldn't he would uh he wouldn't
would that would that be 12 rounds
or just how many an exhibition about
would it just be eight how many rounds
would it be
if it did happen um yeah it probably
probably would be like an eight pounder
or something
at the most i would think but because he
fought uh
conor mcgregor which is not a boxer
either but at least he's a fighter but
he's not a fox
that was 12 rounds so but this this
exhibition now i can't see it
even if it's scheduled it's not gonna be
no eight rounds anyway
no you think he's gonna he'll get he'll
knock him out before eight yeah i mean
technically you're not supposed to knock
out somebody in the exhibition
he had another exhibition against the
japanese fighter and knocked them out in
the first round so
the different rules in different
countries in the states and so so i'm
not really sure
mike tyson roy that's
that's the card you're on now yeah yeah
how do you see how do you see that going
i mean uh i love both guys both guys a
friend of mine
and my two favorite fighters growing up
or or when i started boxing when i was a
teenager
uh was um roy jones and mike tyson so
it's to me it's uh it's crazy that
they're fighting now and they're a
little older but
i just pray that none of them get
injured you know
may the best man win uh what do you what
about
when you were you were were you actually
helping this ksi
who actually fought logan paul were you
helping him prepare for this
i mean i sparred him so i was preparing
for my world title fight
and uh and they came into the gym i
didn't really i didn't even know who he
was
and they said yeah he's a famous
youtuber whatever can you you know
show him some uh around
just for fun and yeah that was it and we
i think it's on youtube but uh um yeah
that was just for fun
and uh my strength and conditioning
coach
uh ahmed abdullah my manager he
and a couple other guys from my team uh
you know uh
helped him prepare for his fight but i
just followed him once
he gave it how was it in the gym do
do you know a lot of times uh nowadays
a lot of times people you know who watch
the media
right now it's kind of toned down but
expected possibly if it does come back
when people start you know
um teasing or they start you know making
certain statements about islam about
certain muslims you know
the haters do you get any of that
feeling sometimes at the gym
you know anybody ever in this
environment you know crack some jokes oh
you muslim you terrorist stuff like that
does that ever happen has it ever
happened to you uh
no it's probably the bad thing to do
that in a boxing gym
something like that no but no everybody
there's a lot of muslims in my gym and
uh yeah no everybody had respect for
each other floyd and them they they
know i'm a muslim they uh you know they
always respect me and
no i have never heard anything like that
have you have you ever had a chance to
sit down and have a deep conversation
with someone like floyd did he ever ask
you about islam did he ever
you know because i mean when african
americans when they look back at their
roots
you look at you know that islam
this is when malcolm x right when
muhammad ali when they went back and
they dug
and they saw that you know this is my
roots islam submission to the creator
not the creation
islam you know this is the roots of the
african-american people
uh has he ever you know asked you any
questions about islam have you ever any
any any talk about it um not yet
not yet but michelle in the future
hopefully
in inshallah what else do you see for
yourself in the future you're doing also
some great work you got this charity
organization
that you're that you're uh a part of
correct
yes so uh this is the body jack
foundation so we we started the
foundation to give
kids all over the world a fighting
chance in life
that's uh our slogan and uh everybody
can go to
uh by the jackfoundation.org so
currently we work with a palestinian
refugee camp
and a syrian refugee camp in jordan
um i have my education center there um
working with kids with education
nutrition and
and stuff like that and also we uh
teamed up with
my uh my my friend abu bakar have a in
gambia where i'm
my dad's from called the spot project so
we're trying to help them as well
they work with orphans and yeah we have
a lot of things going on actually in in
the states
we're going to work with foster kids now
also is this coming from
now getting to know uh this way of life
islam is this what now
encouraged you motivated you now to
start giving back just like muhammad ali
was giving back he was motivated
and now he is a muslim american hero
and people love muhammad ali but what
made him great is islam is what he gave
back to humanity because of islam is
this also what's motivating you to give
back
to humanity islam absolutely
it feels like it's my journey to to
serve my fellow men my muslim brothers
and sisters so
and you know everybody in need too so
yeah we
i want to i want to be a good role model
and
you know get better each day and trying
to help as many people as possible if
i'm
you know i have i have this platform as
a world champion and uh yeah i want to
try to
make the best out of it yeah that's so
important when people have a platform to
use that platform for good
you know that that is extremely
extremely important
because one day it can all be gone and
now you you just forsake the chance of
earning so much edger and good deeds and
this is uh this is really important yeah
you you also
you're good friends with uh what do you
think there's another
match coming up with uh our brother
habib you know habib yeah
i met him by uh one time um
yeah i i don't really follow ufc to be
honest but i i know he got a fight
coming up
in abu dhabi right yeah how do you how
do you see that going uh
i'm not sure who he's fighting to be
honest but from what i've seen
uh you know i don't know too much about
grappling and that stuff but
yeah i mean he's undefeated and you know
i saw him fight against conor mcgregor
yeah
let's let's take it back to uh what
you're more familiar with then tell us
how do you feel when you see a lot of
these youtube
stars now crossing over you know into
this
arena what do you think about that
i mean everybody that's you know
work hard whatever they do if it's not
um
but if they do their stuff on youtube
they they did something right
to get all these followers and stuff so
if they want to do boxing
yeah go ahead i mean i'm not going to
hit on it and i wish everybody the best
but it's you know so some some boxers
don't like it because they work their
whole life
and and for this and they don't they
don't make that kind of money or get
that
uh exposure but uh uh i mean it's it's
the social media era right now so
yeah do you think uh do you
do you think do you think someone like
if uh if uh
um floyd floyd mayweather who he
he actually when you saw that fight
what'd you think about that when he
fought conor mcgregor
were you that were you there were you
there watching it were you there at the
fight
oh so you were also on that card with
conor mcgregor yeah
yeah yeah so yeah that's when i defeated
nathan cleveland for the wba
heavyweight title so yeah i mean it was
uh
the biggest event i've been a part of so
it was huge
um i mean most people at least the
people that is involved with boxing
knew was gonna happen but uh yeah i
think
uh i think floyd kind of just wanted to
he could have probably stopped him early
but i think he just
you know you know wanted to break him
down and
stole the show man [ __ ] for the fans you
know
you think that'll happen again there's
there's talk about
part two you think that will happen
again um
i mean it's possible that nowadays like
they say money talk so
so it's a business move i mean mcgregor
can't beat floyd
in the boxing ring maybe in the ufc ring
but not in the boxing ring but
um they they bought a cell pipe and
you know i heard that mcgregor might
fight manny pacquiao instead now
oh yeah who uh who uh conor mcgregor
conor mcgregor that's the rumors that
he's gonna fight manny pacquiao in the
middle east
yeah that's the rumors what did you
think with all this
when you saw like because we were
talking about keeping it humble i mean
something
you know uh respect and when you saw
habib how he was
carrying himself and then when you had
conor mcgregor
right what was going through your mind
when you saw some of this
like i said i don't follow ufc so i
didn't follow the
all the trash talk before the fight but
i was there and i saw
what happened after the fight and i met
khabib uh in
in dubai he was really humble i told him
about the problem
and everything they represent so yeah
that's like
uh mcgregor is the villain that just
talked and he's the humble guy
and we saw what happened in the fight
yeah
do you do you think someone like uh
let's say tomorrow hypothetically if uh
floyd mayweather if he really looked
into this deem which is based on proof
and evidence if you read the quran and
he said man this is from the creator of
the heavens and earth and he decided to
submit
his will to allah to the creator and now
do you think someone like him you know
him right uh do you think he would
he would be someone who would need uh to
think someone like him he would just
have to have four wives
four it's four is it maximum four
i i take four whites
yeah probably but uh because islam is
practical islam is practical
so this might be a way for some dawah
opportunity right because a man's like
thinking man he wants to be right he
wants to be married but how can i and
you're out there you know and what men
do we don't have to talk about that
but man it gives him a a a a good
great option to be right with his
creator and to do it uh you know
the way that's sanctioned by by allah
[Music]
yeah sure yeah that's beautiful
alhamdulillah you can drop them here and
there you know some of these things have
a person think
because i remember i did a program i did
a program once i remember when he was in
jail
yeah yeah that was years back and we
were talking about that you know it's
like when everything is taken away
and same thing when you're in the grave
tomorrow when you die i mean sorry some
people are just like spooked out right
now but this is a reality we're gonna
die
and we need to think why are we here
where are we going when we die
you know and i remember when he was in
jail he was thinking a little bit
different
and i think i i think i sent him if i'm
not mistaken
um i don't know if we sent him i sent
him a quran if i sent to his jail i'm
not sure
if but we reached out and gave a message
to him you know because that opportunity
when people are in jail
you know all the distractions are away
from you now it's time to really think
and ponder
yeah now i remember it was the brother
from the uk uh another bachelor
that gave him a quran and some books and
also um he wanted to take a picture with
his wife him and his wife and floyd and
floyd
you know because he he he took like
floyd's was going to be in the middle of
the picture but floyd
you know out of respect he got a hijab
on everything
he he wants him to be in between them
but i mean he got a lot of respect
martial allah
just a couple more questions tell me
like so when you're when you're at the
gym you're training
do you like you know you stop just like
you did here and do they have an area
you call a few other brothers who are
muslim at the gym and you guys
go and make salah um i mean usually
um me and ahmed um
basically when i train i have to drink
myself
early in the morning i don't like to
train when there's too many people
around
and stuff so so most of the time ninety
percent of the time
i got my dream for myself so we i always
leave but
yeah it happened to me and i'm um we go
pray together in the gym in the back but
uh you usually i
you know
yeah we see you here in this uh little
video clip you're actually at a jummah
making salah you're praying like jesus
this is how jesus prayed this is how
moses abraham they all prayed like this
they didn't worship jesus moses
they didn't worship the creation but
they worship the god that you're
worshiping
and i just i want to use this example to
motivate the youth to motivate those
others
that might be playing ball and salah
through her time
you know passes they're not with mike
tyson or anybody right they're just with
the boys but they miss salah
but you were with mike tyson and you
were with the brothers and
and the cameras are rolling and you
didn't miss a lot so i want to use that
as
that's a great example for others you
know to not miss your salah how
important is salah in your life in a
muslim's life
i mean that's very important you're not
supposed to miss
you know your salah five times a day and
you know even if it's hard to
help in the morning you know you gotta
do it
or at night whenever it is you know you
know try to
you know live as right as possible and
don't miss it you can beautiful advice
stay connected
we learn here stay humble keep it humble
stay connected
to your to your creator and this is
something beautiful it's beautiful to
talk to a brother like yourself
you know who's proud to be on the dean
who does not shine away from it
and uh inshallah i i love to meet you
one day in person brother
really nice having you on the program
may allah bless you thank you and uh
give salaams to uh brother abdullah
to mike tyson and inshallah we can also
have him on the program sometime in the
future inshallah if you can make that
happen let me know
yeah absolutely i'll i'll do my best
let's see if i see him
friday let's see if we can make it and
what's
what's the name of that charity again
organization that you're part of where
people can go
my name foundation dot org
you can read and see everything that
we're doing
may allah bless you my brother
jazakallah salaam alaikum
and that was my brother your brother
baru jack here on the dean show
and what can we take from that i mean
many people when you get into
you climb the ladder and you train so
hard
and you accomplish so much and then big
paydays start coming in
people start getting arrogant have you
ever noticed that nobody wants to be
around an arrogant person
money can change and has changed a lot
of people
but what and we wanted to highlight this
brother's
journey and his story about what's
keeping him humble
not to say somebody was not humble and
then they accepted islam became
humble no but islam that's one of the
tenets of it
it's supposed to make you a better human
being by implementing it by staying
connected
to your creator five times a day
beautiful example
the brother badu and abdullah they are
at the ranch with mike tyson and what
happens is the her time
now easily what about you take that for
example you're at work
you're a doctor engineer a lawyer a
mailman doesn't matter but the time for
salah kicks in and you're just like oh
some people are not even thinking about
it or you think no what
uh i'll just make it up some other dime
some other
no no no there is a specific time it
needs to be prayed
and this is a great example if they can
do it and stay connected
why can't you you got to ask yourself
that you can you can do it
and when you see people in that position
famous people
celebrities people who now
are staying connected to the dean and
then good company
you saw when mike tyson was reminded the
brothers were like we like to pray mike
where could we pray say go ahead go
ahead and pray but i want to pray with
you
look at that you also don't be shy not
just stopping what you're doing and
praying
but also look how important it is to
keep yourself around
good company because if you're around
people with smoke dope
you're probably going to end up smoking
dope if you're around people who drink
alcohol
you're going to probably end up drinking
alcohol if you're around people who are
going to the strip clubs they're going
to probably invite you a stripper you're
going to end up in a strip club
and you're going to end up committing
dinner and you're gonna end up from
there just
you know how it goes it's not taking you
uphill downhill
but the dean so not only does it help
keep you humble
because you're humbling yourself five
times a day minimum connecting to the
one and only creator of the heavens and
the earth
right and you're not taking money as
your god you're taking the creator to
heavens and earth who's
created you and you're thanking him for
all these blessings you're keeping it
humble
and you're remembering that our life on
this earth is short
it can end at any time so you better get
rid with it
and badu jack he's getting with it and
he's learning more
and he's growing and alhamdulillah this
is a great example for the youth and
other people out there
to get connected with your dean stay
connected learn
grow and if you see people out there
who are proud don't be shy now to be
someone who represents if you're a
celebrity you're famous you're out there
i'm not trying to hear it
here to help promote boxing or any of
these no
but what i am is if you're already out
in that industry
and you are given a platform don't shy
away from representing
this dean just like muhammad ali did and
be a good representation of it
and share it and this is how you can go
ahead
and make a great legacy because all
these other things you're going to leave
behind garbage
i could say i bled for garbage all the
money the thing all this stuff's going
to save me
stay behind but what is going to go with
you your deeds your faith what you
believed
and what you did of goodness in this
life and then at the end you see the
paradise of the hellfire now where do
you want your final day
destination to be people save up a lot
and plan for that holiday vacation
or their retirement island but now that
also
will be over when you die
that's it bye bye but what we do is like
badu jack is doing he's planning now
seeds of goodness with this charity that
he mentioned
keeping it humble staying connected to
his creator always making toba going
back going back
and getting ready to meet his creator
and this is through islam submission to
the creator not the creation so
i'm very uh very happy and elated when i
see brothers like this
and inshallah many people who have
abandoned the salad who've gone away
from their deen
you know hopefully this can be a little
bit of encouragement motivation
and other youth who are out there who do
their sports who play maybe do some jiu
jitsu
who um do some martial art but when it's
time to makes a lot
they are not even thinking about it but
if this brother can think about it and
do it you could do it too
you can do it too we'll see you next
time here on the d show subscribe if you
haven't already
and support us on our patreon page we'll
see you next time peace be with you
assalaamu alaikum
and if you like this episode of the show
like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now
you